there was a lot of excitement among
Metal Gear fans this weekend who was
certain they were gonna get their next
taste of Metal Gear Rising revengeance
the character action games spun off from
the main series the number two flashed
up briefly between shots of upcoming ps4
games in a Sony sizzle reel shown during
the 2015 type a game show this would
have been an odd yet pretty mundane
occurrence had the number not been
stylized very similarly to the Metal
Gear Rising logo unfortunately even
though Metal Gear credited a Okajima has
been meeting with rising dev button
games and this is totally his style it
might not mean much of anything a senior
producer at Kojima Productions confirmed
that he doesn't know what the truth
stands for and suspects it's just a
countdown number it's a Sony Computer
Entertainment made trailer he said oh
well let me know your theory on the
mysterious number two is Kazuma trying
to throw us off the scent or is a call
of the game being teased we'll keep you
updated so stay tuned against what